just one day before an alabama man was
set to go on trial for the murder of his
ex-wife a shocking new confession turned
the entire case upside down
carl harris was charged with murder in
2016
26 years after the death of his former
wife tracy
48 hours correspondent maureen maher
spoke with harris
and shows us why prosecutors suddenly
dropped the case against him
the day before his trial was supposed to
begin
dale county district attorney kirk adams
and ada
jordan davis spent years building a case
against
carl harris for the murder of his
ex-wife
tracy tracy harris was a hard-working
young mother that disappeared march 7
1990.
a week later her body was found in a
nearby river
based on the autopsy the manner of death
was homicide
i think from the very get-go there was
only one suspect in this case
carl harris the couple had recently
divorced
and carl had a girlfriend carl harris
did have a reputation
for being very violent in particular
towards tracy harris
about a dozen witnesses gave
investigators statements describing carl
harris's physical abuse of tracy
something
carl denies i never put my hands on
tracing
never so all those people were lying yes
ma'am
i love tracy she was the love of my life
despite the suspicion
no arrest was made and the case
languished
everybody thought i killed him
everywhere i turned they
they you know you hear him whispering in
the background there's a man that killed
tracy
then in 2015 an ozark police cold case
unit
took another look at tracy's murder and
again
zeroed in on carl the evidence was
circumstantially strong more than
26 years after tracy harris was killed
carl harris was arrested for her murder
who else would want this sweet innocent
young lady
murdered the prosecutors were confident
in their case
until they got in touch with a potential
witness for the trial
dawn beasley a friend of tracy's jordan
and her team had spent a lot of time
building a case that i was about to
torpedo dawn would upend carl harris's
murder trial
just days before it was to start and
point prosecutors to the real killer
i kept the secret for 30 years
and maureen maher joins us now maureen
good morning that's dawn there at the
end
why would she keep this secret for 30
years well she was told by that person
keep the secret don't tell the police
and also that it was an accident and it
it's
important to remember she's 21 years old
at the time this happens
pregnant and scared she was scared that
if she went to police
they wouldn't believe her and that the
person might then deny it who was the
person who confessed to her if you can
say without giving too much away oh you
know tony you've got to go home put that
cute baby to bed and sit down with you
watch it on saturday night can you at
least tell me what happened to carl
harris the ex-husband
yes i can so of course the trial does
not go forward
charges are dropped the problem for carl
though is that he felt he spent
his entire life under suspicion as the
main suspect
so he hasn't filed notice that he
intends to file suit against the city of
ozark
his problem isn't with the prosecution
it's with the police department
and its investigation all right maureen
thank you very much
and you can see maureen's full report
the 30-year secret
the tracy harris murder on 48 hours
tomorrow night at 10
9 central right here on cbs